hallo leute wusstet ihr euch schon
einmal für ein forschungs gespräch auf
deutsch vorbereitet habt ihr bammel vor
dem gespräch und möchte bis nie welche
sätze auf euch zukommen könnten
die innerliche und mentale vorbereitung
für ein vorstellungsgespräch ist schon
aufregend genug
daher ist es gut wenn man sich zumindest
mit der sprache einigermaßen fit führt
dabei hilft euch hoffentlich unser
heutiges video wir werden euch einige
typische fragen vorstellen denen ihr bei
einem vorstellungsgespräch begegnen
könnten so los geht's fiona feierabend
hat sich bei einer agentur für
künstlermanagement beworben
hallo mein name ist mini maus haben
sekretär gefunden h
ja ich bin fiona feierabend ja es war
voll wie sie meine freunde mich her
gefahren der folge gute orientierung
kennt ihr vielleicht schon ist weg
fitness influenza
ok feierabend wie sind sie auf uns
aufmerksam geworden
wie sind sie auf uns aufmerksam geworden
ja ja ja man könnte ja also ich kenne
mich mit stars und stillen voll gut aus
also ihren namen kennt man halten und
deswegen ich wollte schon immer hier
arbeiten klare sache
und warum möchten sie bei unserer
agentur arbeiten
warum möchten sie bei uns arbeiten ja
wie schon gesagt ich kenne mich in der
welt der stars und sternchen super gut
aus das ist voll meinten meine welt also
wie wird man künstler was macht einen
künstler aus wie wir man berühmt frame
und so also das soll mein ding
meine freundin sagen einander leben für
jona wärst du berühmt härteste irgend
talent also ich habe
leider keine talente dass das problem
ich kann nicht sehen wie ich schaue ich
bin nicht ok kommen wir doch mal zum
nächsten punkt erzählen sie doch mal was
über sich wer ist fiona feierabend und
warum denken sie dass sie die perfekte
kandidatin für die position sind
erzählen sie etwas über sich
warum sind sie die perfekte kandidatin
für die position ja also über mich
selbst ich würde sagen dass ich echt von
offenbar vor freundlich
viele sagen auch ich bin auch ganz aber
ich sehe das gar nicht sonne also ich
arbeite an meiner karriere ich will ganz
nach oben und ich weiß wie man dahin
kommt das finde ich jetzt nicht arrogant
ich glaube das verbindet mich echt mit
den klienten hier ich weiß was es heißt
künstler zu sein und irgendwie groß
rauszukommen
und ich glaube ich könnte den alle echt
best friends sein ich habe eine
unglaublich gute menschenkenntnis gesagt
echt jeder und ich weiß wer ist der
mensch hinter dem künstler ja welche
eigenschaften würden sie als ihre
stärken und welche als ihre schwächen
beschreiben was sind ihre stärken und
ihre schwächen
also stärken ich bin echt ärgerlich
das ist eine stärke auf jeden fall
erfolgt ist echt witzig dann bin ich
einfach echt zum komplett also sagen
zumindest mal ist und ich glaube ich bin
noch witzig also mir kann man echt spaß
schwächeln
naja irgendwie hat ja jeder sprechen
oder bin ich vielleicht perfekt
vielleicht bin ich auch perfekt aber
irgendwie ja ich würde glaube ich sagen
dass morgens schlecht aus dem bett komme
sondern schwäche aber immer künstler
welt ich glaube jeder künstler ist so
und das ist auch okay
bei unserer arbeit ist es wichtig sich
gegenseitig feedback zu geben
denken sie dass sie kritik fähig sind
wenn ihr zb eine kollegin sagt fiona das
war gar nicht gut wie reagieren sie dann
sind sie kritikfähig wieder reagieren
würde da würde ich erst mal sagen mädels
erst mal wie du deine eigene arbeit
gemacht hast ne erst mal vor der eigenen
hause gerne nervt zwar manchmal aber
weiß was hier rein daraus
welche position nehmen sie in einem team
ein
ja auf jeden fall eine führende position
ja also ich merke schon es nehmen sich
viele mir ein beispiel ich kann als
leader ist voll mein ding ich merke dass
meine freundin ja ich frage mich immer
alles und ich sagte ihm auch echt immer
was sie anziehen sollen und so deswegen
das wäre schon mal ein ding
kennen sie eine schwierige situation aus
ihrer bisherigen beruflichen laufbahn
beschreiben und wie sie damit umgegangen
sind
wie gehen sie mit schwierigen
situationen um ja
dieser französische dj daniel beschützer
der hat mal bei uns im nachtclub
gespielt wo ich damals gearbeitet habe
aja wie war das wie war das also
irgendwann so
mit sony music
[Musik]
ich meinte die schwierige situation also
ach so na ja also auf jeden fall war der
total anstrengend der typ der hatte
irgendwie so eine ganze an courage dabei
alle super und coole typen und ich muss
jetzt auch gar nicht aus
super schwierige situation aber auch da
sag ich neuer tag schwamm drüber
warum haben sie bei ihrem letzten
arbeitgeber gekündigt
ja das ist ja schon etwas länger herne
also ich würde sagen ich glaub der grund
war die kam einfach mit man freigeist
nicht so klar ich bin auf jeden fall
sehr viel spiritueller als die und es
hat ein wenig sorge passt der und die
letzten jahre habe ich damals für genuss
mich persönlich weiterzuentwickeln
ob es würde ich sagen so wo sehen sie
sich in fünf jahren
wo sehen sie sich in fünf jahren
da kann ich nur eins sagen ganz weit
oben also natürlich bei ihnen wie sie
sich vorstellen können ist unsere arbeit
mit den künstlern streng vertraulich wie
gehen sie mit vertraulichen
informationen um
wie gehen sie mit vertraulichen
informationen um das ist echt meine
stärke hier kann man alles erzählen also
meine freundin gabriela fall ist es
richtig mist gebaut bei ihrem freund
betrogen
ich habe aber gesagt ich es keinem
gabriele keine menschenseele
[Musik]
ok haben sie noch weitere fragen haben
sie noch weitere fragen fragen noch
keine fragen
doch doch ich will ja wissen der justin
die isn der so ist er persönlich so wie
man das so denkt schon arroganter typ
oder kann mir schon vorstellen und dann
halt doch doch ich habe eine frage und
zwar in sechs wochen wollte ich mal
fragen kann ich da wohl urlaub nehmen
also wenn das hier alles klappt
natürlich weil ich habe schon mit meiner
besten vor eine kreuzfahrt gebucht jolo
so ich hoffe ihr habt einige fragen und
wörter für forschungs gespräche gelernt
vielleicht weniger von fiona aber ihr
habt sicherlich einige fragen gehört die
euch in einem vorstellungsgespräch
begegnen könnten
wenn ihr jetzt noch einige übungen zu
diesem thema und anderen themenfeldern
machen wollt schaut doch mal bei page in
vorbei als mitglied bekommt übungen zu
all unseren videos bis bald
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
yum yum